what happens at hogwarts stays at
hogwarts
at least until now
these young actors dealt with
embarrassment because of mischievous
monkeys falling asleep while filming
laughing at the worst moments awkward
kisses and so much more these may be
memories the actors would want to forget
but right now
we're all about them
oh my father heard about this
not in front of everyone poor emma was
so nervous to hug little radcliff and
grint in front of everyone on set
filming chamber of secrets a very valid
reason when you're 11 years old you did
test positive for cooties reluctant
watson wound up hugging radcliff and
just shaking her eventual husband's hand
we're putting down we're just such good
friends the hug itself was tricky to
capture since watson's arms barely even
made contact with radcliffe leaving the
team no choice but to literally freeze
the frame for a few seconds so you don't
miss it if you just happen to blink
congratulations i can't believe you
solved it
this set was bananas maybe the only
thing harder to wrangle than a bunch of
young witches and wizards were the
monkeys included in mcgonagall's
transfiguration class these animals made
filming pretty awkward with their not so
safe for work behavior let's just say
these actions wouldn't have flown if
they were humans the bats on set weren't
innocent either one went so far as to
urinate on rupert grint rupert maybe got
peed on by a bat at one point as well
sounds like it would have been a rough
day for the animal handling and wardrobe
departments
did james phelps mrs morning coffee
while he could have been getting really
into character we have a feeling the
actor was just catching some z's during
his own death scene yeah super casual
everyone had long days on set but the
busy schedule got the best of the fred
actor who fully fell asleep and then was
left alone in an empty great hall
what's my line it's crazy i have no
words for it the pressure is real
all eyes were on tom felton who got so
frustrated and embarrassed trying to
remember his lines that the young actor
fully started crying unable to get the
words out chris columbus had assured the
wee malfoy that it was going to be okay
and the team captured what they needed
but in the end it wasn't so true
the line didn't even make the final cut
poor little tom that's probably the last
time he forgot his lines
[Music]
you got me tripping ooh stumbling emma
watson was well prepped when she filmed
beauty and the beast the actress went
through all the trip ups she needed
filming the yule ball sequence in harry
potter and the goblet of fire now don't
swing your arms okay her dress and heels
were gorgeous but combined with all the
eyes staring at her waiting for the
perfect fancy hermione reveal well it
made for a pretty rough session that saw
watson tripping down the stairs over and
over and over again
i was absolutely terrified i was going
to rip it or spill something on it or
anything
harry and hermione in a tree
k-i-s-s-i-n-g
the kiss obviously had to be
passionate
i was half-naked and covered in silver
paint so that was pretty awkward not
only do they passionately make out they
did so while scantily clad making
kissing a co-star who was like a sibling
extra awkward just don't do it giggling
grind became too much of a distraction
that watson had him kicked off the set
so the awkward kissing could be done and
over with as quickly as possible
it's honestly like kissing my brother
kissing rupert
was so awkward
not one but two awkward kisses and emma
watson with rupert grint was literally
dubbed the most uncomfortable filming
experience she'd had in her career so
far it's purely the fact that he's like
my brother sure plenty of people would
be lining up to plant one on ron weasley
we're looking at you lavender but watson
um i mean oh it was awkward yeah
no matter how you put it just awkward
grint had some feelings about it too
just it just felt so wrong really
who made that noise
sure they acted strict and serious but
alan rickman and michael gambin had
their fair share of fun even at the cost
of throwing daniel radcliffe under the
bus in front of a room full of people
dan has us to have his sleeping bag next
to this particular girl that he fancy a
giant quiet room full of students and
sleeping bags
how can an actor not take advantage of
such a perfect situation cue remote
controlled whoopee cushion really really
funny and for you the sly addition into
radcliffe's sleeping bag controlled by
gambin we enter completely our own world
[Music]
led to a lot of laughter from pretty
much everyone except the harry potter
actor
and then there are young children who
are scared of me it was embarrassing for
helen a bottom carter and straight up
painful for matthew lewis being as
bellatrix as ever bonham carter got a
bit too feisty i was just torturing him
and i thought it would be fun idea to
use my wand as a q-tip
you know and just give his ear clean but
then it went too far and yikes
and i i think i actually did draw blood
inside his ear the neville actor was a
good sport about it but jeez
that's a hard one to live down even for
lestrange she's sort of without limits
we'll just let molly take care of her
not my daughter you
step one two step one two and
again you trust me
it's awkward enough to be going through
puberty on camera for the whole world to
witness
but dan didn't even have time to learn
to waltz i'm actually a really fantastic
dancer but because harry's not very good
i felt like a player
we don't think the parabola actress
minded taking the lead though
it is just a rehearsal
but it's not in the book like her
character emma watson was so well
studied up on the og content that she
wasn't too sure about this particular
awkward moment between harry and
hermione should be included at all the
team ended up going ahead with the scene
but it remained the one in the first
deathly hallows that the actress felt
really embarrassed filming
give her an inch and she'll go a mile
i'm not really sure what i was thinking
a fair warning to anyone who might have
to do fight choreography with emma
watson be sure to make it clear that you
don't want to see her fist up close she
just went
and just smacked me right across the
face
but if we're being honest we can't deny
the fact that we all kind of loved
seeing that punch land
that felt good
not good
brilliant
quiet on set
that includes you grant rupert finds
everything funny it's cute for a while
but at a certain point the amount of
time rupert grint spent laughing on the
set got him into enough trouble that it
was downright embarrassing to think this
was happening for eight movies
you'll ask him what were you laughing
and he got i don't know
[Music]
let's throw way back to the early 2000s
while we see the young wizards face and
think it's just adorable it's a bit more
of a cringe fest for the actor himself
if i can i avoid ever watching to be
honest we'd probably feel the same way
if millions of people were watching us
at that age
does the embarrassment never end for
grint it was his hair in the fourth film
that really made him cringe
watson wasn't a fan of her awkward
teenage stages being captured on film
this is actually quite traumatic for me
and radcliffe well he was just plain
embarrassed by his acting choices it's
not an enjoyable experience to be fair
though for a preteen the boy who lived
knocked it out of the park some of these
were pretty brutal
we definitely wouldn't want these
memories to be captured on film forever
which situation did you think was most
embarrassing